all right guys thank you for joining us
we have a guest on uh merch can you
introduce it and I'll get it all set up
here yeah I'll introduce him because I'm
sure our audience isn't familiar I me of
course yes ladies and gentlemen
inexplicably sluming it with us for a
half hour uh Jimmy door ladies and
gentlemen hello Jimmy how you doing man
Jen how are you good to be here thanks
for having me of course man we're happy
to have you on thank you uh so much for
for coming on this is a kind of a big
get for us if I seem very if I seem low
energy it's because I have a the 2023
flu I'm just getting over it I've had it
for like 10 days it's a real son of a
[__] it's way worse it's 10 times worse
than Co I'll tell you that yeah good
we're well we're leaving for Vegas today
and we get sick every time we go so we
have that to look forward to yeah but
that's an STD that's a different thing
that's not the thing that you're that
you're talking about yeah you're right
that last trip was a little yeah man we
appreciate you coming on we we are we
are fellow Rumble Brethren we're also
over here on on Rumble hang and it's
been great honestly being over here has
been so we got kicked off of YouTube for
cyber bullying Jeffrey Epstein we were
bullying Jeffrey Epstein um YouTube
thought we were going a little hard on
Jeffrey Epstein so they didn't like um
you know us making jokes at his expense
yeah so I got uh in trouble they said
that we were harassing uh Justin
Trudeau what h i mean
it's targeted targeted harassment that's
what we got yes we got Target for
Jeffrey EP we got targeted harassment of
a uh an Infamous dead pedophile who ran
an island for it so I and but enough
about
Trudeau but what did you now because
YouTube obviously is not very um they've
never been very transparent with us
you're obviously a little bit bigger
than us so maybe you might have gotten
more information from them than we ever
got did they ever clarify what specific
you did to uh uh you know bully Target
and harass no I did a video that showed
people protesting Justin trau that was
it that's it it's it is really it's it's
staggering especially when you find out
like behind the scenes like we've had a
little insight we've known some people
that may or may not have worked over uh
over in that area in YouTube at alphabet
in that specific area yeah and we've
heard that like you know people think
it's this huge Department of like tons
of people and you're like who's you know
who's reviewing these it's like four or
five four people and they're sectioned
off they have one person higher higher
end users right they have one person
that covers the political sphere just
for what they consider right-wing people
and one people that covers it just for
they consider leftwing people it's like
four or five people that are at the end
if it gets high enough make these
decisions so they know who you are like
every they know who anyone is over like
anybody that's had more than two strikes
it's literally like working in a call
center it's like working in a you know
like a telemarketing Center and you're
going oh yeah I got Jones again you
remember that guy yeah that guy's such
an [__] he came up in my leads again
it's they they know you after a while
and they don't well I used to have H I
used to have a leaz on uh with YouTube
the I had that lison for at least
probably four years and it was very
helpful he was very helpful uh in a lot
of ways and and um in in the biggest way
was to to keep us on the right side of
their censorship
uh that he left a couple months ago like
maybe four months ago now and to pursue
other things he left Google YouTube and
uh they have not replaced him so it
doesn't look like they're going to do
that for us yeah they're GNA let us
twist in the wind they do that and they
do that and then and then then the then
the couple then they they'll just what
they did with us when they wanted to
gone was and this is the tactic was like
we had like a thousand episodes on
YouTube so what they'll do is when they
even if you're being a good boy now
they'll go back to four years ago find
an old video where they've changed the
rules Since By the way we like it was
fine when you said it four years ago but
even though it was fine then now that
they changed the rules it's not fine and
hit you with a strike they retroactively
just hit you so why do you think it's
taking rumbles so long to become to have
parody with YouTube not I mean not with
numbers but just technically like it
seems like uh don't all don't all nerds
know the same [__] and why is why can't
they just copy what you YouTube does why
is it so hard I I don't understand that
we've been saying the same thing man
that that that's that's been our thing
where it's like I I know they they keep
saying they want to build the tech from
the ground up but we're always like look
man you don't have to follow YouTube's
philosophy but if their Tech works right
copy the tech like I agree look we want
and we want to be able we want people on
Android phones to be able to donate they
can't and that that sucks you know yeah
I I've dropped I've dropped a very dirty
word in the past to them at Rumble and
they didn't like when I said it but um
and this is a dirty word in a lot of
circles but it's like any other thing
that gets misused the algorithm can
actually be a good thing corre when it's
not abused right and I think that Rumble
is very much like no no algorithms we
don't want any recommended stuff and
it's like no YouTube's algorithm used to
be a very handy tool because it would be
like oh you like cat videos and you like
uh guitar videos well we're going to be
slinging all these cat and guitar videos
that you didn't even know about and then
it became like well we don't know if
this cat owner is a right winger or a
left Winger so we're going to start
censoring this cat video over this
guitar and it's like so if you don't
abuse an algorithm and I think Rumble
needs to implement some sort of
algorithmic uh recommended stuff so that
you get more stuff in your feed and you
go oh I never heard of this guy but he's
pretty cool and I I think there's a lack
of that and I also think a lack of um
diverse content I think when you go on a
website and the splash page is all like
a trump and
Qing a we're the storm and you know it
you go oh God where are the cat guitar
videos well I I think that's what it is
I think I everyone at least for me I
want Rumble to be what YouTube used to
be that's it I don't want it to be
political yeah I want I want every I
want everybody to be able to say what
they you know for the most part they do
but it's like the I agree with you the
tech needs to catch up big time but I
mean right now it's the only place cuz
now when you get you get get kicked off
of YouTube where do you go you have to
come here go I want to go back to the
YouTube where everyone was on there from
like I mean the the craziest like left
Wingers all the way to like Flat Earth
and Owen Benjamin that was Peak YouTube
I want them all on there because I want
to go on my show at night and make fun
of these people and YouTube's making it
real hard to pull these clips of you
making an ass out of yourself because
now I can't find it I got to go to
Odyssey are you kidding me so yeah I
want to go back to a time when you go
what was that crazy [__] Nick Fuentes
said the other day something about yeah
something about like uh gay anime girls
and and nazzi said pull that clip for me
and you can't anymore yeah so it's it's
kind of they're kind of I've always
believe that you shine a light on these
things to make fun of them not um hide
it and and they're hiding everything now
and now YouTube Just is is just crappy
TV well that and all the you know I'm
sure Jimmy you know about this the
medical information stuff is we got a
lot of strikes for that man yeah I've
heard you dabbled in that Jimmy yeah how
did that go for you I get that's they
got me on that too and and um they they
said that
um I I I said that the vaccine didn't
stop TR well I had figured out early on
that the vaccine did not stop
transmission uh Dr Robert Malone told me
that it's called a leaky vaccine and
then I started to look into it and I
noticed that a lot of the countries that
had the biggest uptake of the vaccine
were also having the biggest outbreaks
of coid and so I started to report this
to them and I said you know the vaccine
does not stop transmission
which it does not so they took down I
think five of my videos and they gave me
a warning so that's the first thing
before they give you a strike and um I
said I showed them how the FDA
themselves said they don't know if it
stops transmission they hope it does and
so when I showed them that they go oh no
it's because you said it doesn't stop
contraction and they just changed it
they just so they obviously just like
the Twitter files if there was a YouTube
files I would find the the the the email
from Big Pharma or Dr fouchy or the
white house or somewhere that said you
got to go at Jimmy door and so they did
and they they tried to put a scare in me
and they had to appease somebody and I'm
sure it was a big Pharma Advertiser and
uh so they did and and they just made up
a reason to do it and of course we all
know now that the vaccine doesn't stop
transmission or contraction because they
never even tested for it and the reason
why we know that is because scientists
and doctors went over this vaccine trial
data because they wanted to keep that
hidden for 75 years we know that because
an European Union Parliament member
asked a fiser executive if they ever
tested to see if it stopped transmission
and contraction and she laughed and said
of course we didn't so I was I I was
correct so I got I got in trouble for
again being correct and you're not
allowed to be correct when it comes to
their advertisers of the establishment
again you don't get in trouble for
telling the for telling a lie you get in
trouble for telling the truth just like
Tucker Carlson he didn't get fired for
lying they they hired him to do that
they fired him because he told the truth
about the military-industrial complex
our imperialism and then he started to
tell the truth about big Pharma and that
you can't do
that same thing with uh John Stewart
just happened recently they just fired
John Stewart from his own show that's
not the similar he was talking about
China and Ai and apple that's the reason
they gave you a good boy
what okay fair he is he is a good boy
fair enough all right John Stewart went
on Steven colar show and he told the
truth about where the coid virus came
from the Wuhan lab and he was uh he
admits so if you saw he he him and his
own crew talked about how he was on the
outs from polite Society for that people
said they were done with him they hated
him and they were never going to watch
him again and so he didn't get the
invites to the parties he wanted the
people he wanted to hang out with now
hated him and so he had to go back and
pin a medal on a Nazi at Disney World
and he had to give a tongue bath to cond
Lisa Rice and Hillary Clinton and then
do a whole panel on lying about vaccines
uh just to get back into their graes and
so if you pin a mod medal on a Nazi for
the military-industrial complex they'll
give you an Emmy nomination which is
exactly what happened and nobody's
watching his show you know I went on
Twitter and talked about I how they were
uh getting rid of his show show and
people were like I didn't even know he
had a show so that's the real reason why
they're getting rid of him because he
doesn't have any [__] viewers that
show sucks it's a woke disaster and um
and so they gave him a cover story hey
we'll make it look like you're a bad at
this is my theory by the way I have
no but the evidence I do have is that he
pinned a metal on a Nazi and he's never
going to be made to answer for that he's
never going to have to apologize for
that it's never going to even be brought
up and he's never going to go anywhere
that would bring that up and and then he
also gave a tongue bath to two of the
biggest bloodthirsty warmongers in the
history of the world cond rice and and
Hillary Clinton and then he decided to
do a uh a show on vaccines and did he
invite on Dr Robert Malone or Mulla or
anybody else who had a counternarrative
no he invited three hacks who lied about
vaccines and lied about the coid vaccine
and lied about their policies and so
just then then he got a pat on the head
and now he's he's allowed back into
polite Society uh that again don't he
was he was a kind of a quasi hero for me
because I was very admiring of the job
he did with that show he had but uh you
know Chris Hedges used to tell me Jimmy
he's not really challenging
establishment and Chris Hedges was right
as soon as he challenged establishment
they came down on him and he got his he
got his mind right as they say yeah they
do you know that's something that you
you are more more now like they they the
way they teach these people the lesson
is like public humiliation it's it's
it's where they have to come back and
they have to like you said depending on
what your woke crime was in John
Stewart's case like you said he had to
pin a medal on a Nazi that's you're back
look we're going to let you back to the
parties but you better go give this Nazi
a medal you're not coming back and
that's how it is or they have to
apologize or for having an opinion like
a opinion you think if you think John
Stewart was going to be a badass and
tell the truth about China or whatever
hey why why wouldn't he tell the truth
about Ukraine he'll never tell his
audience the truth about about Ukraine
because they would cancel his ass
immediately and he would never tell the
truth about vaccines or coid or the
lockdowns cuz they would cancel his ass
immediately and he so he didn't no yeah
I mean and and I think with all of this
stuff going on I think you'll agree with
me the only person that could fix it is
sen 2020 former right hey let's go huh
what did you think of that we're running
we're running on a platform of n bombs
and horse [__] it's crazy that's what
it was it's the my one of my favorite so
that immediately they were like you're
not a US
citizen well right there I mean that's
just the clown show that it is he's not
a US citizen and he points to a a
decision by the Supreme Court that said
you can't discriminate against natural
born citizens and naturalized citizens
but in that ruling they specifically
said except for when you're running for
president of the United States so the
ruling he's citing actually contradicts
what he's saying he knows that that's
the used car salesman that Jen yuger is
Jen yuger calls himself a lefty and a
progressive yet he's pro- censorship
he's pro-war he's
anti-union that is the opp and and he
was for all the [__] with coid and
the he's a big Pharma shill so he's the
opposite of what you would normally
consider a lefty but he's definitely a
Democrat oh yeah when did The Mask like
slip off on the left because like I
remember occupy right like I remember 11
years ago Jesus it was a long longer
than that actually uh yeah it was a long
time ago and I mean like I I remember at
least people being like hey these Banks
man they're they're they're raping us
and these pharmaceutical and even the
pharmaceutical thing like we went from
like H I don't really trust big Pharma
you know it was always a joke like
daytime television it was always 500
commercials running about class action
suits and then boom just like like just
in the blink of an eye everybody got
like a firmware update but like when was
between occupy and now when did the left
just start being like I don't know War's
pretty cool dude and you know like what
do you think the flasho for that was I
think Trump Trump's election it wrecked
them and so anything they thought Trump
was for they had to reflexively be
against even though he brought us the VX
even though Trump brought us the V and
somehow pouched it that Trump was
against all that it was like him against
fouchi even though Trump and him were
having pretty much the same line and
they all warp speed he still wants
credit for it which is going to hurt him
I think in the election oh it's very
much hurting him yeah and so that's why
the Democrats wanted to push RFK J out
of the Democratic primary because they
think he'll hurt Donald Trump more than
he'll hurt RFK Jr I mean more than he'll
hurt Joe Biden but um so that was the
whole St so yeah that was it so if you
can cou something as being uh anti-trump
that's when the the [__] Libs as I call
them would embrace it now you know this
whole left right thing I remember uh so
my audience has shifted and it used to
be mostly Bernie Sanders uh followers
and people who are on board for for
Bernie Sanders uh but then Bernie
Sanders showed his true colors and I was
on the Forefront of exposing him for
being a shield for power and a lap dog
to uh to the Democratic party and the
establishment which he is he's a willing
liar and uh and he's an enemy of the
people and so what once I did that a lot
of those Bernie Sanders people started
to turn against me but a lot of people
uh on the Right started to perk up to me
because I started to tell the truth
about Russia gate I debunk I was one of
the first shows if not the first show to
debunk Russia gate to debunk the Syrian
gas attacks and to talk about how these
are all coming together and and so uh
and now I'm I'm trying to show people
how they're using the RICO statute to
prosecute Trump and to prosecute stop
cop City so anybody who goes against the
establishment they're going to
criminalize so my audience now is like I
would say it's it's hippies it's
right-wingers and it's everybody in the
middle so I have a a much more diverse
audience than I used to and I had a
comedian open for me a couple of months
ago and when he came off stage he goes
oh you know your audience is getting a
little rightwing there huh and I go well
what do you mean by rightwing they're
against they're for freedom of speech
they're against censorship they're for
bodily autonomy and they're they're
anti-war so now you tell me is that left
is that right what is that exactly all
those positions I always thought were
Lefty I always was taught my body my
choice well the de the goddamn Democrats
totally get so if you go against that I
don't think you're a lefty anymore
you're just a woke Maniac that that has
got nothing to do with being a true
Lefty a true Lefty is for freedom of
speech absolute a true Lefty is for
bodily autonomy absolute and a true
Lefty is against War absolute and so
they're not that so I don't know what
those [__] people are anymore people
call them left I call them Democrats
well I I think I think a big I think a
big CU you know the same thing with
there's no here's the thing there's
nobody that there's not an anti party
anymore there isn't one we don't we used
to have one there there's not one they
they're both of them want to go to work
if you always want to see what the true
colors are when there's certain things
they vote on when they all vote together
I always like worry about that worry
about that because that's the uni party
and that's really what I think it is
it's that and and and even and that's
why they tried to make Matt Gates they
tried to make him out to be a pedophile
Y at first I was like why are they doing
this to this guy and now I know why
they're doing it to that guy because
they knew they couldn't control him so
they tried to discredit him and scare
the [__] out of him and he didn't Buckle
so I disagree with Matt Gates on a lot
of stuff but I'm all for him uh what he
did in the House of Representatives is
what I thought AOC and the squad would
do they would stand up against Power and
they would decouple bills they wouldn't
have you voting on a school lunch bill
and tied to Ukraine funding at the same
[__] time and with a border Bill all
that and so he's for so he's for the
kind of reforms that I thought the left
would be for and so I'm all for that guy
and he's against funding the Ukraine war
now we disagree on other Wars but I'll
take his uh uh his solidarity on that uh
yeah I like Matt gates for one simple
reason when people ask me why I like
Matt Gates so much he's the only guy in
my lifetime that I've watched on TV
literally almost get punched in the face
by another Congressman because he was
making them so angry and I like any guy
that goes no you know what if my
weekends ruined yours is too we're all
[__] coming in to work this week get
your coffee get your thermos bring it in
and I don't care if you want punch me in
the [__] face and that's what I like
about Matt Gates it's like I don't think
we're going to I honestly Beyond
thinking we're ever going to vote our
way out of this mess that we've gotten
into as a country God willing we will
but it's pretty much a mess so at this
point anyone who just comes in and goes
no I'm going to torture everybody and
everybody's coming to work we're
canceling a vacation and I don't care if
we got to vote 80 times on the same
thing we're going to just keep coming in
I love that about him so that's that's
the thing I like about the country is
not run by Congress or the president
obviously the country is run by a
handful of billionaires which run the
goddamn whole world and right now
they're practicing criminalizing their
opponents like they did to Lula and now
bolsonaro in Brazil and how they did in
Pakistan and now they're doing to Trump
and again I'm no fan of trump just like
they criminalized the January 6 protest
right they made all those guys out to be
like they're they they were trying to
overthrow the government I don't know if
you know this a bunch of Second
Amendment gun nuts showed up to the
capital to overthrow the government and
son of a [__] they forgot their guns
yeah no I know that's the worst insur
Insurrection in the history of
insurrections by the way every one of
those people had a bounty of guns they
they bring they bring we're talking
about your core demographic trust me
they had plenty of long guns at home not
one of them brought one yeah what what
do you think now what do you think now
with this uh even with the potential of
another Middle East War now what's going
on uh with Israel and Hamas like I mean
how do everybody in in Washington both
sides like we got to go we got to get in
there and it's I'm worried we're going
to have another 18 years of being in the
Middle East with no
goal yeah well I love how they say
Israel is the only democracy in the
Middle East you know why cuz we
overthrew the [__]
democracy true 100% it's 100% you know
Lebanon used to be really nice Iran used
to be beautiful uh yeah there were a lot
of nice places remember when he start
tried to start his own bank and then
America always shows up with a cartoon
bag of money and we're like Hey we're
your pal man don't worry and then your
government is CED within 10 years nobody
nobody ever wants so they want to go
bomb Iran they they've been itching for
a war with Iran for a long time and they
say it's because it's a theocracy and
the reason why it's a theocracy is
because we overthrew m in 1953 with the
CIA because he wouldn't share his
[__] oil with us and that's and so
then and then it turned into a theoc
then we had a puppet in there called the
Sha until a theocracy and the Ayatollah
came over and over through and that was
all instituted by us just like you know
it's called blowback right and they even
have a term for it they know they're
doing this and so just like with when
they invented the the musah Hardin in
Afghanistan to fight the Russians and
then we ended up [__] fighting them
for 20 years but we weren't really
fighting them that just like Julian
Assange has proven these wars are not
meant to be won these wars are meant to
be ongoing yeah because you have you
have to F you have to fund the mil you
have to fund rathon and and then and
everyone gets there has their hands in
their each other's pockets and I think
with Trump look we have a we have a lot
of criticism for Trump too we're people
that voted for him but after the VAC
stuff well you were saying earlier is
true a lot of people turn him because of
the VAC stuff after the VAC stuff we're
like [__] this guy you know what's he
doing with this I voted for him twice
and I feel personally betrayed by the
guy so you know and I will say and I'll
say this though the the one thing that
he did that I liked was he did not get
us into any new Wars any more Wars and
they tried to they even tried to put
Bolton in there to do it they remember
that they put him in let's do it I truly
believe they would have let him be
president again if he just got us into a
couple of Wars but they'll they'll never
forgive him for the war it's not about
any of the other stuff it's not about
the in or the classified document it's
about the biggest sin he did was not go
to war and they they they will never
forgive him for that that they will
never forgive him well he ran on uh
ending the Middle East Wars and pulling
that money and pulling our troops out of
there and spending that money at home
and that's when they decided to rush
gate him to begin with that's what that
was all about and so yeah you're exactly
right and you know they peached him for
putting a pause on we shipments to
[__] Ukraine that's what that was
about too and why did it take him so
long to impeach him because they had to
find a crime that he committed that they
weren't all complicit in yeah no that's
exact exactly right they couldn't do it
because they were all they were doing
that and and now we're fighting a war on
two fronts and people get angry at you
and it's like look man I'm not
saying the middle Israel has every right
to defend itself and I get that but if
you've lived through 9/11 this is
starting to feel a lot like that it's
starting to feel like emotion
that's this is how you get the Patriot
Act this is how you get the Patriot Act
I have been blown away by watching like
on Twitter how many people have just
like I understand if you're if you're
Jewish or if you're Israeli and you're
saying we got to wipe out Hamas we got
to wipe out their leaders this has to
stop you know whatever but I I've been
hearing like we got to wipe Gaza off the
map we got to Glass these people like
the amount of just blood blood lust that
I'm seeing on Twitter and I'm like whoa
like I've never I've 911 not since 911
do I remember this I've been cancelled
I've been kicked off YouTube I've been
called racist I've been called like
we've been smeared by the splc for being
like white supremacists when he's not
even I'm I'm Cuban by the way all these
things and then like when you see this
kind of stuff and I'm like I can't
recall in the last decade when I've ever
called for the blood of anyone even
somebody I personally hate I'm like you
know what [__] them I'll write them off
I'll block them I wish them all the best
just you know I don't want to hear that
[__] but the amount of just oh it's
really scaring me what do you think the
end result of this is going to be what
people don't realize is that you know
Hamas wasn't invented by Israel but
might as well have been because they've
been funding them yep and in 2019
Benjamin I just reported on my show last
week that Benjamin Netanyahu said if you
if you support Israel you have to
support funding Hamas why is that
because Hamas will keep the Palestinians
split right there there's the secular
there's the San Palestinians and then
there's the radical uh religious
Fanatics the Hamas and so if you can
split them you that's that's good for
Israel also when they do do terrorist
attacks then Israel can use that as a
pretext to go in and do what they've
always wanted to do which is Slaughter
those people and take their land and so
that's why Hamas is very invaluable just
like Isis was or Al-Qaeda was to George
Bush Dick Cheney and the establishment
they couldn't then went on a killing
spree and set the Middle East on fire
for the next 20 years they did Iraq they
did Libya they're doing Syria they're
doing uh Yemen they're doing somal
they're doing all kinds of [__] the
Sudan even and so they and they're all
doing that under the pretext of the aumf
and that's and they'll never get rid of
that because they want to keep doing
warmongering everywhere and again these
wars are not meant to be well and J why
the real reason why what I talk about on
my show is the real reason why the why
did the establishment hate Donald Trump
they loved him my whole life they loved
him they he was a guest on every late
night talk show he was a guest host on
Saturday Night Live many times they gave
him his own network television show for
10 years where and they gave him Emmy
nominations and Hollywood stars came and
bended the knee and called him Mr Trump
they all played golf together they all
went to each other's uh kids weddings
their kids are best friends with each
other so why did they all of a sudden
decide to hate Donald Trump right it's
because they'll tell you it's because
he's a big liar and if you think they
hate Donald Trump because he's a
politician who went to Washington DC and
started lying that means I I've got a
vaccine I'd like to sell you the reason
why they hate Donald Trump is because he
would accidentally tell the truth every
once in a while like when he said
there's a deep State and they control
everything and they want more war and
then would he say asked him why are you
leaving troops in Syria and he said for
the oil so he just gave the whole game
away the real rod for American foreign
policy is to invade smaller more
powerless countries and kill their
people take their natural resources and
give it to Western corporations and the
whole world saw him say that and so they
got to get rid of him and yeah then then
you have you have Lindsey Graham on
there who's also like if HB even does
one thing we're going to war he's so
deep in the closet he's flying Christmas
presents I'm so sick of him I'm so sick
of all these people yeah lindsy Graham
was great when uh when the Ukraine stuff
started and he went on National
Television like the second day and was
like you know it would just be great if
somebody in Russia would just
assassinate him if you're watching me
right now hear my voice somebody kill
Vlad Putin please and I'm like what are
you doing like he's oh my God man just
bloodthirsty like you said they they
they're sipping on a mul siing on a mul
praying for dead babies and it's you
know and and that's and that's basically
that's that's where we are man and I and
I mean the question is people tell you
like you know have hope have hope have
hope but it's like they want you can't
can you vote your way out of it you
can't because every time someone comes
up they blot they they destroy them
immediately so that's that's that's why
they came down so hard on the Canadian
truckers because the Canadian just like
Ralph nater they he was they were
setting a template for how to stand up
against the establishment right and so
they can't have that so that that's why
they came down and the truckers were
vaccinated at a higher rate than the
general population they weren't
protesting medicine they were protesting
[__] authoritarianism and they were
right and they were Heroes and Americans
are so propagandized we look at the
truckers who are Freedom Fighters and
call them Nazis and we look at literal
Nazis in Ukraine and we call them
Freedom Fighters That's The Power of
propag Anda and that's the world we're
living in and my what I try to urge
people is to don't let them turn you
against your neighbor because they did a
control demolition of our economy during
coid that smashed everybody economically
except a handful of millionaires and
billionaires and they want me to blame
my neighbor and be angry at my neighbor
because they wouldn't take a vaccine
that didn't work the way they said it
did in the first [__] place because
what scares them is that I'm going to
join with my neighbor and that we're
going to wake up that we're all being
screwed by the same handful of [__]
billionaires and we're going to join
together like Christian Smalls did with
the Union on Staten Island now Christian
Smalls started the first Union for
Amazon on Staten Island and he did that
with a bunch of trump voters that's a
black guy organizing a bunch of [__]
Trump voters Against The Establishment
and that's what scares the [__] out of
them and more than anything so if they
see left right and people losing those
political labels to come together
against the the oligarchy economically
that's the only thing that scares them
so they keep us fighting against each
other which is why they do identity
politics I identity politic all this
trans [__] and all that it's not coming
from the bottom up it's coming from the
top down it's coming from Vanguard it's
coming from Black Rock and they want us
to all identify by Race by gender by
ethnicity by whatever the [__] anything
except a grown class lines because
that's a real threat to power dude amen
amen Bravo seriously 100 100% on point
here spoken like a progressive from 10
years ago yeah seriously exactly
exactly spoken like somebody that 10
years ago we called a liberal isn't that
crazy does it worry you though that like
like I'm glad you brought up the turning
on your neighbors thing cuz you brought
up the Canadian truckers and it's like I
had jobs when I was younger where once I
figured out oh we [__] people over at
this job I would quit right but I feel
like it doesn't worry you that more and
more people nowadays are just in it for
a pension and just like I If I were like
looking at this Canadian trucker bank
account and I'm like oh he has
$311 in his checking account I'm
freezing it cuz the boss said so I don't
think I could click the button it seems
increasingly more people are willing to
click the button now does that worry you
uh I think people always were willing to
click the button that Stanford study
proved that so if somebody in Authority
tells you to do something you'll do it
so uh I just think they're ramping it up
on steroids now and uh they you know
that's the whole point of this digital
currency so they can control you people
don't even know what the [__] WF is I
had Cornell West on my show he's
clueless to all that [__] he's clueless
to the [__] coid authoritarianism he
calls Dr fouchy a man of integrity I
mean they got everybody snowed and
nobody's but worth of [__] is standing
up and saying anything except RFK Jr and
then of course now he's [__] the bed
when it comes to the Middle East he's
not calling for a ceas fire a pieace
he's calling for he's giving blanket uh
uh approval for for them to go in and do
a genocide he's put he's coupling China
Iran and Venezuela together he sounds
like [__] Dick Cheney it's he's
wrecked his anti-war coalition and he's
wrecked his presidential campaign so we
got nothing I don't know what honest
people don't realize that our country is
really run by a handful of all that
[__] coid stuff all that policy came
from the who who runs the wh goddamn
Bill Gates so I'm not allowed to
contradict anything Bill Gates says
because I can't go against what the who
says according to YouTube and Google and
so that's being dictated to by Bill
Gates cuz he's their number one [__]
donor you got to love medical stuff is
being run by somebody who made a shitty
operating system yeah remember when Bill
Gates tried to block out the sun like Mr
Burns yeah that was one of his ideas
he's going to block out the Sun and and
it's fine that was a real thing yeah
they they're they're they're they're but
how do you think we feel we had uh we
had DeSantis and we loved them cuz we
were like wow he didn't lock down we got
a great like potential presidential
candidate and then he's like not only do
we need to fight in Israel and Ukraine
frankly I want to start drone strike in
Mexico and we're like what what like the
GOP debate was literally everyone going
no I'm way bloodthirster than this
[__] he ain't [__] I want to Nuke
like three countries I think what
happened with JFK junor was people
forget that this what kind of with the
John Stewart then you mentioned earlier
when when he was they they they they
accused him of being an anti-semite
earlier before the the homas thing a
couple months ago remember they accused
him of that and he was like I'm not what
are you talking about and now it's like
you you want to keep you want to keep
running or you want to and then it's
it's just Scare Tactics they they label
you the one thing I'll say that is good
like their propaganda doesn't work as
much as it used to because even in 2016
if somebody called you a NAU like you
would defend yourself but they' they've
made the word meaningless like all these
words become meaningless you could call
me whatever you want because I know who
you are and it doesn't bother
me um I I I agree how about that yeah
and and Jimmy thank you so much for
being I I know you had a heart out and I
really appreciate you being on thank you
so much for coming on man you slummed it
with us and we much appreciate that that
was that was great man my pleasure
Revenge Revenge of the cyst take it easy
Jimmy take you can find him on Rumble
yeah Jimmy Door Guys in case you never
heard of the guy in case you never heard
of this young up and com yeah he's this
kid's gonna make it take it easy Jimmy
see you later than guys I'll talk to you
later byee sure uh Jimmy Roman that was
wow that was fantastic we get real
guests on this
show